foreign
come together hard to believe coach
Bedner's eighth season behind the
bench for the house one of the longest
tenure to the National Hockey League
is the [__] comes into the app Zone and
Byron will take the hit hey stripped Hansel
gives it up and that puck is all the way
down the ice a quick clear by Smallmouth
30 seconds to go in this Avalanche kill
it could off
ering ball three shot there the
circle where Paul shoots and he scores
short side is colasar [Applause] was right in
front of Georgia providing the screen in the
Vegas golden knights with a power play goal have
taken a one-nothing lead borderline interference
watch 55 in front here just planting his spot your
gift can't see in and they definitely knowing your
Traders I'll take that back and we had a great
angle here that was short side just about two
inches above the pad pretty much a perfect shot
here's a great look at it look at that right
above the pad nice screen junior hockey team the
nylon Clippers had 110 points with 59 goals that
season so he knows how to score yep he knows
how to shoot that block and that was wide down
hunting slams it ahead Here
Comes Vegas again with Morelli
cleared out down low an opportunity not once
but twice and that was a great kick save with
the look back I always talk about like a pinball
machine watch The Flipper folks it's not there
and then it is that's just the perfect save
he's so good down low so athletic and when
you're a smaller goaltender meeting I'm not sure
I've ever seen the more previous interference
sometimes guys try to disguise him a
little bit ABS haven't had a shot on
goal in the last seven minutes we'll
see if they can break something up
Johansson to Druid Byron finals and walks in
and shoots and that's off the glove of Thompson
Jonathan Drew him he always got skill he's
gonna be on the power play in the regular
season depends on which unit in the slot
deflected saved by Thompson a couple of
bounces off the Stick of Poland split
back up top Byram will take over again
Byron that's creeping in there's a rear shot
peg in the way and that's what
he will do the big defenseman
right away is viral walking in allows and looks
and he fans out as Richard just slid off the end
of his blade and now there's two broken sticks
on the ice two and a half players essentially
for Vegas into the slot that Miss Johansson
well the ads can do a lot of damage with two
guys out there with no twig everybody creeping in
Byram in the slot shoots and that's blocked away
30 seconds to go in the power play
no shots on goal so far officially
drew it Johansson shoots
it's all in one game but he's able to get his
stick on it over to Drew and watch this he
just grabs it and releases it with no time and
probably puts 85 miles an hour on that wrister
just right there what a beauty Middleton
of course he's been in the organization
for a while but size is back a little bit
every minute to go here period number one
[Applause]
[Music]
Logan O'Connor creates a turnover rate there
good almost and then let's skill take over
what a beauty little backhand pass go back
to the fiber those are the kind of goals in
exhibition games that can spark young Talent at
20 years old allows and comes in boy that's got
to feel good for him at the end of the day
what sweet hands he had 11 goals last year
he's an all-around complete player the best
second line Center in the National Hockey
League according to me the two centers the
ABS acquired in the officers Ryan Johansson
and Ross Colton are both excellent at the
dot so look for more of that coming up in
the regular season as wall brings that puck ahead
for Vegas golden knights played last night in San
Jose we have a penalty coming up it's going
to be a high stick and it's going to be on
wall Oscar allows in the former first round
pick with a tally here already this evening
there's a steal s for heads on his rooster
off his stick Byron Milwaukee a drag move
d by Myers and is saved by Patera well
Byron trying to find people tonight not
shooting that puck nearly as much as he
normally would roll the knights back it's
a nice Walker and stuck right with
that puck right before the horn inside
he couldn't get all the mustard on that
now watch use this ottoman comes across
let's keep it going I want an action
third period because the second was
stuck in the mud just a little bit just
a little bit here we go Ryan Johansson
as he got into Hague in a big time wing
long drive there never got to the front
of the net and Patera trying to chase
him with his name [Music] [Applause]
[Music] says that creates the chaos down below
and then he Giselle muscles his man to the front
of the net what a slick little play right there
from Holland and Curtis McDermott just pulls it
in but that entire shift was based on big
number 56 the work ethic and they're moving
them up front I'd say based on today's
game that's quite a bit of early success
well you're on his tracks you better
watch out because he brings that in
all of your wind is gone he's right back into
the play what a great job yeah and you know
playing defense you got to play with a little bit
of poise but you can be Reckless up front I think
that fits his game real well that last shift in
gorgeous proof [Applause] you'll find the red line
and Cormier sneaks in to bang it home
and make it a 3-2 game Lucas Cormier
from the back end this face driven into the
glass walk right there that's the play that's the
turnover and then quick as it can happen bing bang
you get watching the puck and it's in the back of
the net that was more of an NHL caliber style play
and how fast a turnover can go into the back side
that's a learning moment there but just like that
Vegas is back in it he's saying hey easy guys you
got to keep it clean keep it clean and that's
a way to keep the game moving nice job outlook
finds Connor here he comes Sean flew a tire in
front same my Eustis on it they get a stick up
here's Houston's on it and keeping it no carryover
players could spend almost every guy who's in Camp
they get at least one game then Myers now six and
one at the Face-Off Circle here in this evening
[Applause] is coming up Vegas
will keep control of the puck
do they know it's a delay call cross-eyes pass
into the skin we'll take a look right here I might
just gets behind on Barney's position he's got no
choice so here we go exciting 20 seconds while we
talk about face-offs Brian Johansen out there for
this one the biggest wins it kicks it up top here
knocked Away Joe Hanson made the play fair brother
six seconds to go here's the final run [__]
[Music]